a military aircraft scours the area
where an army helicopter crashed into
the ocean in the northeast of Australia
debris has been located but 24 hours
after it disappeared there was still no
sign of the four Australian defense
Personnel on board
our focus at the moment is finding our
people
and supporting their families
and the rest of our team
it was part of the largest ever military
exercise with the United States as the
two countries strengthen their defense
cooperation in the region at the annual
ministerial talks there was Mutual
aberration from partners with a
long-standing Alliance
it is about operationalizing the
alliance in order to ensure peace
stability
an order in which
Prosperity can be attained to attain
that Regional stability the US will
expand its military footprint in
Australia sending more troops fighter
jets and bombers as well as invest more
in the country's Air Force bases
Australia will also Fast Track plans to
manufacture missiles for the United
States after the Ukraine war exposed the
danger of Western stockpiles being
exhausted and we're racing to accelerate
Australia's access to Priority munitions
through a streamlined acquisition
process
response is the security agreement
between the U.S Australia and the UK
known as orcas which will provide three
nuclear-powered virginia-class
submarines to Australia the United
States says despite some resistance from
Republicans threatening to delay the
legislation it will get support in
Congress
we will be seeing an increased tempo of
visits from American nuclear powered
submarines to our Waters China says the
growing relationship Under The orcus
Pact is embracing a cold war mentality
and is a threat to Regional security but
the alliance says Australia needs
nuclear-powered submarines to monitor
the changing military strategy in the
Pacific
America's top Diplomat says China's
influence and expansion of the region is
the greatest threat to Asia Pacific
we're doing that in part by engaging
China but also as necessary opposing its
efforts to disrupt freedom of navigation
overflight in the South and East China
Seas
to upend the status quo that's preserved
peace and stability across the Taiwan
streets an accusation that China has
already denounced Sarah Clarke Al
Jazeera Brisbane